welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar automatic
detection and classification of behavior
in laboratory animals it is presented by
Patrick Sweeney PhD founder and chief
operating officer of Nissan science my
name is Judy O'Rourke and I will be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laberd's lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email following the presentation if
you have trouble sing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits and now without further ado
please join me in welcoming dr. Sweeney
I will now turn the presentation over to
him
thank you Judy
just to preface this it's becoming
apparent for some time that the things
that we're doing in laboratories are the
best majority of laboratories nowadays
involved still involves a lot of manual
collection and manual observation and
these things are very still very
valuable and there's still a lot of
skills to be learned and a lot to be
learned from the animals but what we're
actually starting to understand know as
as we go further into the 21st century
is that what we're doing in the very
amps and however hand handling
laboratory animals has a fairly profound
effect on the quality not only of the
experience of the animals when they're
in that variant but also the quality of
experiments that we might run down the
line in terms of function in terms of
cognition and in terms of behavior
essentially anything that we're doing in
the Bavarian can cause disruption to the
animals and until very recently we
didn't know how long that actually
lasted or what that aspect actually was
one thing that was actually very
important to us was that the kid site
assessment just in terms of lab
resources if you have a lot of animals
in the laboratory or even though you've
only a few animals cave site assessment
is still very very important both from a
veterinary health point of view and also
from the technical point of view to make
sure that the animals are functioning
and acting as they should the cage site
assessment due to a resource issue only
occurs once or twice a day the ability
to monitor animals over a 24-hour period
seven days a week would be very very
valuable up until very recently this has
been this has been very challenging and
equally challenging to be able to do it
in a group house environment the way
that we handle animals to be in
laboratories we're learning a lot about
that and about how the best way to
handle them is essentially any way that
we handle animals and interact with the
animals
disrupts their date and now again can
have a fairly profound effect on studies
that occur down the lines particularly
those studies when we're dealing with
function and behavior and tasks that
need to be that need to be completed and
when we're checking for cognition so the
handling of animals has been shown to be
to have a fairly detrimental effect if
we do it the wrong way but even if we do
it the right way interacting with the
animals is not something that that
that'd be like so we look at how we
monitor animals currently in a in the
end of a barium environment we're only
getting a snapshot in time with that
cage sight assessment we want to know
more about the animals and we want to
know more about what's happening when we
can't see them we want to know how they
interact with each other and we want to
look at the causes of injuries and
unexplained death so very often the
anecdote is that technician comes in in
the morning and you see that there's a
one less animal in the cage one animal
has expired we don't really know the
reason for that and in a lot of cases
and it'd be very good to be able to go
back in time and be able to look at that
but as I said a snapshot in time is
essentially what the kids say assessment
is so we want to be able to help monitor
animals longitudinally 24 hours a day
and look at those cases where the
animals are actually suffering or when
we can assess them at those times when
they should be interacting socially we
want to be able to look at what is the
normal behavior of an animal and its
home caged environment
the motivation for the system that we
have brought is essentially the things
that I just mentioned rodents or social
animals isolationist stress is stressful
for them the interaction of the
laboratory staff scientific staff these
things are all stressful on the animals
also again the primer primer
predominantly nocturnal and we would
really love to be able to see how these
animals are interacting with each other
what kind of behaviors they show at
night when the lights are off and we
want to be able to from a quality point
of view establish baseline behavior
profile so before the testing we want to
know is this cohort of animals acting
the way cohorts of animals of this type
should be acting so are they conforming
to that phenotype and then during the
study we want to be able to look at the
effects of the handling on these animals
of the tasks that we're making these
animals perform and we want to want to
find a way to understand that these
animals are actually staying normal and
then from a surveillance point of view
we want to be able to look at welfare
monitoring so the indications of adverse
effects is there a possibility that
these show up sooner if we're monitoring
the animals at night if there are the
things that when there's no one in the
room when there's no technicians
interacting with them do we see
indications of adverse events and this
is actually something that's coming to
the forefront now in laboratory animal
sciences the handling of animals and the
surveillance of animals and the ability
to monitor welfare without doing those
cage state assessments
and there's been a lot know over the
last few years published in this area
it's a particularly fascinating area and
I think that the quality issues where
the effect of the environment on the
animals and the effect of of handling on
animals and hold that pose are impacts
downstream studies and cognition in
behavior I think that that's very
important and that's something that we
are continuing to look into and
continuing to refine ways to pull data
from that and and overall it's a quality
control issue with in laboratories
nowadays
so there's been a lot of public
cases on this and they'll be a lot more
and at the end of all you have the
automated cage ethology that that's
springing to the to the front node and
their various sad devices are there
various technologies that want to study
that the behaviors of mice these want to
look at it as I said initially long
eternally but there are fewer devices
that are actually looking at animals in
their social context in their home cage
so a lot of these are task oriented the
animal is still working in isolation or
or living in isolation when it's in that
environment so it's probably more but
more valuable and probably more true to
the actual phenotype to keep the stress
levels of the animal done as low as
possible and to look at them when
they're group housed and to have it in a
typical page so that when things like
cage changes are made or when
technicians are interacting with them
the environment isn't overly different
if we can if we can control that then it
stands to reason that we can have a
better control downstream when we're
actually running a lot of the task
oriented assays that we would like to
run in cognition and behavior
so in 2011 along with the Mary Lyon
Center the most Research Center at car
well the MRC at the University of
Edinburgh and actual analytics in
conjunction with sponsorship by the nc3
ours took up the cracking challenge and
the cracker challenge was created to
address some of the concepts that we
I've alluded to previously here so in a
regular homepage essentially any any
cage in any lab areum that was IBC
compatible to maintain the social
housing of animals so that they wouldn't
be in isolation with very little impact
on husbandry and to give us a 24/7
insight so a longitudinal insight into
what was occurring in the home cage
minute-by-minute second by second day by
day month by month if it had to happen
and on top of that we looked at home how
many key behaviors would we be able to
start to analyze automatically through a
form of machine learning in the home
cage in that social environment and from
that came the actual analytics homepage
analyzer it consists of an RFID chip you
can see there's very very small fits
into either the flank of the mouse or a
pouch in the in the stomach or it can
even go into into the back it doesn't
affect the Moses
gay or most kinematics in anyway there's
a computer and the camera and you can
see that this the cage that we're using
could be pretty much any any IBC tej the
setup itself has a 360 nanometer or 860
nanometer LED
infrared lighting above the kids and a
PC core i7 with an HD ready 720 25
frames per second camera so we're
monitoring essentially 25 frames a
second 24 hours a day seven days a week
and we're looking at those behaviors
that are occurring in that home page and
the social setting and it's actually
quite quite interesting what we get from
it when we look at what's happening in
the light phase and what's happening in
the dark phase and particularly when
there are no operators involved we
generally show a video at this point but
we want but what you're actually what
you can actually do here and what you
have we're actually showing is that you
have an automatic identification of each
Mouse I each position in the cage and a
catalog of behaviors that those mice may
be carrying out whether its nest
building drinking from the water spoke
feeding from the hopper showing
aggression towards each other
grooming so there's a various various
catalog of behaviors the machine learns
those behaviors it creates a classifier
and then that starts to automatically be
tabulated and at the same time you're
measuring from a base plate so you're
measuring the local motor activity and
then there's an algorithm that brings
that together with the camera so that if
something were to occur see it in the
middle of the night that was unobserved
by by an operator you would be able to
flag that the de Madrid system would be
able to flag that for you and you would
be able to go and actually witness what
happened at that point in time so what
we've actually started to see is that
certain phenotypes that are known not to
be aggressive when their hosts together
do actually get quite aggressive and in
the dark period or they do actually get
aggressive in the light period when
there's no operators around or the or
vice versa we see mass building in some
animals where what
supposed to be mass building that did
not happen when it was being observed
and essentially the most important thing
is we can actually see the social
interaction we can see how these animals
are interacting with each other we can
see the social hierarchy within the cage
itself and that comes out both in the
automated analysis and and the ability
to annotate specific pieces of video and
go back and analyze those specific
pieces of video so interpreting the base
plate doctor the base plate works in
concert with the camera if we're just
looking at local motor activity we would
see something that you see in the bottom
left essentially it looks like a whole
lot of lanes going across a checkerboard
but what wire machine is actually
showing that is what you kind of talk
about if we had an observer from the top
time looking at it they would be
essentially drawing something that was
close to that sort of the film line the
field blue line on the field green line
but when we actually have the machine
doing it the machine learns to do it
quicker and quicker and we have what you
see as the sort of the unfilled lines so
when we do the valuation we manually
annotate the position will be channel
every second and then the Machine learns
that starts to do that and then it
calculates the distances that the
animals are moving and that correlates
the distance so that's from the camera
and then that correlates that distance
with the base plate and as you can see
from the graph on the top right hand
side as the machine runs this it gets
better and better so that eventually the
machine begins to observe the animals
and track the animals again 24 hours
seven days a week if you needed it in a
way that is significantly better than a
single operator and even more
significantly better than two operators
doing it and this gives us a good idea
of social interaction between animals
and this slide that we're looking at
right now again with a video would we
would be able to sort of show you this
how the video looks for this but
regardless the statistics that come off
from this actually can because it can
identify each animal individually we can
look at and might obtain that they spend
interacting with each other and this
kind of time they spend away from each
other alone with the distance that they
spend away from each other so that gives
us one idea of the social interactions
in the in the cage and also gives us an
idea of the overall hierarchy within the
cage and this actually becomes quite
important from a husbandry point of view
it also becomes important from an animal
welfare point of view because when we
see animals that are underweight and we
don't quite know why or we're looking
for drug effects we're looking for
resources Asian affairs and some models
or resources a Chanel - we've extracted
an animal and gone and either scan there
or put in another assay where it may
have been isolated for some time the
resourceful ization is actually very
important and some animals don't
resourceful eyes right away and other
animals resourceful eyes immediately so
we can actually see that if there were
any detrimental effects of subsequent
assays on these animals
you
the next slide actually shows that you
know when we move animals so we have a
graph you have three graphs here you
essentially have three different screens
of animals each line in that graph is
the amount of activity over a 48 hour
basis you can see that the light cycle
and the day cycle those are cut off into
twelve other sections you can see
immediately empirically that you you
have a lot more movement in the dark
cycle that's to be expected what
actually comes out of that is what you
see under the red arrows that some
animals handle disturbances or
anticipate disturbances like movement in
the in the the barium cage changes some
animals actually anticipate these better
than other animals and some animals
actually continue with more actively
into the light phase than was previously
known so the end of this active phase
lays on depends on what string you're
dealing with so we start to see they
discrete differences between strains and
very discrete differences between what
is happening the circle up on the top
left hand corner is essentially a cage
change to this this shows you how the
animals are reacting after the cage
change and how long they they will react
to that cage change so we'd also be able
to give you that quality control measure
that you could take in two subsequent
assays so if your animals are not quite
settled down
if this circadian rhythm is is in some
way disrupted there's been - if you've
had an accommodation period that hasn't
been long enough once the animals have
entered the vivarium then you'll
actually start to see this quite visibly
on your computer screen and it's easy to
parse that is easy to find individual
animals that are reacting the same as
other animals and it's easy to see
animals that aren't socializing and
way that we would have thought that they
would have
so as possible just from looking that
Kate sight checks are not actually
showing us everything that we see so
they don't really capitulate that
undisturbed cage and we can only check
those cages so often in a day but what
you're actually seeing here is a trace
of that motion over 48 hours and you're
seeing how active those animals are you
can see obviously that during the light
phase they're spending there's a lot
more down time and then there's a lot
more active time and you can see exactly
how that could those animals are during
that phase
when we look at stereotypical behaviors
and hyperactivity and especially in
terms of endpoints what we're actually
showing here is you have three separate
animals there's the blue lines the green
line and the red line and you can see
that the red light of the circle story
the red circle animal almost immediately
is showing more hyperactivity during the
dark cycle and you know that carries on
over over a few days to the point where
it's really moving a lot during the dark
cycle and during the day cycle you can
see that it is it's slightly more
hyperactive but not something that would
stick out from the other animals in the
cage
when we look at it closer and we check
the cage we actually start to see that
at the time we tried to cave the animal
didn't look hyperactive at all and if
you look at the subsequent cage checks
on the necks on day two at the same time
that animal itself isn't showing any
different than any other animal and in
that cage yeah I had those times and
we're not checking the cage as we move
into the dark cycle the animal is
incredibly hyperactive so whether this
was drug effect or whether this was
simply an animal that was that was not
conforming to the phenotype of the other
animals in the cage or whether there was
something that was wrong with it
centrally we had still gotten to the
point where
you know as these checks at the end of
those checks we had had the humane
endpoint for that animal it was moving
stereotypically in a way that that just
wouldn't allow us to use it in further
studies we probably could have
intervened earlier with that had we been
able to look at what was happening
during that dark cycle so if you look
particularly again at day 1 and day 2 at
the dark cycle you consider that animal
is acting differently than the other
animals in the cage
so the consequences of not knowing that
would be putting on that animal and to
put some functional or behavioral assays
and having that have an effect on the
end results from those ashes
here's another example of what we're
seeing
Romney from the observations so again if
we're looking at these animals
continually throughout the dark craisins
really the light phase we see that with
this with this group of three c57 black
6 males we have roughly 25 cages so all
of those numbers at the bottom are
separate cages and we can see that we
have one hyperactive subject in one cage
and that animal is actually pulling the
other two with it so that phase and the
light phase if we had checked that cage
we wouldn't see anything abnormal but
during the dark phase we can see that it
is an extreme outlier and not only is an
extreme outlier it's also cooling these
other two animals with it so one
hyperactive animal in a cage that we can
spa is essentially creating the other
animal or creating that environment to
be relatively unsettled and pulling
those other animals with it so if we and
we did when we remove that animal from
that cage we actually see that the
hyperactivity or that the level of
activity in that kids along with the
other animals pretty much settles done
we were particularly interested in being
able to look at welfare deficits and we
looked or the MRC and some of the other
partners looked at a group of animals or
different groups of animals that had
different phenotypes in this case we had
a good example from a specific
neurological mutant that animal you can
see is in the center of the screen kind
of lying on top of the tube
now if you look at the top at the
distance traveled in the top left-hand
corner you see the light phase and the
dark phases lab labeled that animal
itself is the animal that was traced in
blue during the day we don't see any
differences in the interaction that it's
spending with the other animals so it's
interacting Spain but we see at night
that the amount of time that is not
moving is actually significantly
different than the other animals so our
our trace in green pretty much shows the
single animal through the dark phase and
the trace in red and blue are the other
animals and the blue animal itself is
the one that you see in front of you
most clearly and we can identify the
fact that that animal is actually quite
sick so simply after a 24-hour trace we
can see that how are we to look at it in
the day time examiner in the daytime it
would be saying but where we to look at
- over 24 hours is interacting with
animals a lot less and it is also moving
a lot less than the other animals in the
dark phase when it should be moving just
as much as the other ones
we can find social isolates so in a
particular mutant for social isolation
we can see that the interaction between
specific animals and this is being done
automatically is giving us this
interaction between that animal and the
other animals and the other animals in
the cage and each other and we can see
that the Royall type a and b interaction
both day and night is significantly
higher but the interaction between
either of those animals and the social
isolate mutant is significantly lower
so that's conforming to phenotype we can
detect that phenotype and we can spot
and for this case and in very many other
cases we can sport that animal that is
the outlier we can spoil that animal
that has a different phenotype than the
other animals so the ability to label
animals
discreetly and to be able to
identify each animal and each behavior
discreetly over time and distinctly over
time is very very important and we think
that this is actually essentially giving
us a very different view of the dynamics
both within the cage and within the
Bavarian and between operators and the
animals than we've ever really had
before particularly when we've been
dealing with animals that were in
isolation or when we were only checking
the animals in their cages and their
homepages once per day or twice per day
so again listen the kind of graphical
reader that you get we had established
that that there is a lot less
interaction between the mutant and the
other animals and this is what it
essentially looks like so you can see
from Tracy that you have a lot of
interaction between animal one on the
top role of Tracy and the second role of
Tracy but virtually no interaction
between those two animals and the third
animal on Tracy so during the dark phase
the social isolate the mutant is keeping
itself very very far away from the other
animals again a video shows this a lot
more succinctly
so I'll just describe it for you the
animal there is labeled you can see its
individual label we can tell that's a
social isolate and the other two animals
are essentially underneath the hopper
and it keeps itself at considerable
distance from those animals pretty much
all the time
we also now have the opportunity to look
a lot deeper at normal behaviors and
also to be able to do things that we
formerly looked at in animals in
isolation so things like rearing nest
building claiming drinking eating social
transmission preferences aggression
grooming we can have that recorded for
us and we can have that actually
telling them the machine is actually
telling us how many times the animals
will do these on a daily basis if one
animal stops doing it it'll give us the
social distancing between those animals
and we can actually start to see that a
lot of the behaviors that we would have
normally seen in isolation if we take
the animal or take it to a different
room look at two in isolation those
behaviors manifest themselves
significantly differently in the home
cage and what we're actually doing with
that is creating a repository of exact
terms of what is happening or what the
condition of these animals what
behaviors are they actually manifesting
and then we're making informed decisions
about what assays to run are these
animals capable have we met the ethical
endpoints for certain animal or are the
conditions in our variance which able to
for these animals and that can change
change from transgenic to transgenic pre
mutant to mutant but the fact remains is
that we're thinking about at night from
the animals point of view why is
actually happening in the home cage was
the social status within that cage and
how is that status affecting welfare of
the animal and how can we intervene if
we have to
here is another slide that shows
actually we the philosophy behind the
system as well as mechanically how the
system works you have a blue tracing
which is the baseplate racing and you
have the green tracing which is overlaid
on that that is the tracing from the
camera and both of those go hand-in-hand
and what we've got here is an animal
who's on one of the kids features is
standing up to eat from the hopper so
the base play is no longer measuring it
when we look at that and if we spread
that time I you see it's a fairly
significant I'm going to obtain that
it's spent on top of that ensure we
didn't see any base plate data but the
because the camera is recording and
because the algorithm works in concert
with it basically on the camera we can
tell that it's not no motion for the
animal the animal is actually standing
and eating so we go back to that point
in time and we look at that particular
piece of video and we see the
explanation for why we suddenly got no
local motor activity data from the base
plate and I think that's actually a
particularly valuable feature of the
system is the fact that you're not
simply recording with a base plate and
you're some not simply recording with
the video you actually have both of them
working together and concert an
algorithm that pulls them together so
that you're getting a complete view
three dimensional view of animal animal
behavior and that social setting in that
and that home cage setting
so as I had mentioned previously the
specifications are that it's a truly HD
video you have like 25 frames per second
what you see over the top is an infrared
lighting panel each setup has its own
PC core i7
computer and then what we actually do is
we capture a small number of examples we
build classifiers on those examples
those classifiers go on to cut your log
examples and it's a sort of a
self-training group from that and then
we test that classifier on the remainder
of the examples and we get these
distinct behaviors whose distinct engage
behaviors in the social setting there
are certain challenges is to keep
designing classifiers faster and to get
enough quality annotations for it so
specific behaviors that may be unique to
a particular phenotype we need to
identify those we can do that when we
get that video and then we start to
rebuild the classifiers from that and
then hopefully and in most cases it
works fairly seamlessly we can start to
identify individual animals distinct
behaviors and look at those animals
discreetly with respect to the other
animals in the cage itself and we get a
menu that would look something similar
to this with the behavioral annotation
you can see from the two panels that the
pictures are at the top of the slide
each animal is I didn't identify it
individually this is an overlay
obviously an operator wouldn't need to
see this they wouldn't need to know
which animal was which but on its own we
can actually start to look at you know
after a period of annotation we can
actually see the periods of aggression
you can see which two animals were
aggressive towards each other
can we see when they're drinking we can
see when they're feeding we can see when
they're grooming we can see general
locomotion so you can see if one animal
is moving a lot more than the others we
can see the rearing and we can also see
the social grooming so when they when
they groom each other
the approach
just involves using local primary
patterns to what we would actually do is
programming the features in the cage
rather simply so that we have we know
where the water spot is we know where
the feeding Harper is and we know where
some of the features in the cage are
these Camilla and somewhat and then we
can spot the animals and then when we
know distinctly what the animal is doing
locomotive behavior we can actually
start to see is actually drinking or is
just spending time around the water
spoke it's actually burrowing for
something or is actually is it actually
nest building going on is actually
sleeping or has actually expired these
are these are the things that we can
start to look at and they've got very
very closely with with this system
our approach to this would be
essentially using those trainer e
patterns understanding the features in
the cage being able to recognize those
and then understanding that near the
waterspout is a region of interest track
from the animal to the water spot and
then how the animal drinks when the
animal is drinking and what animal in
the cage is drinking that all helps us
to build the classifiers for this and
then that is supported through a certain
amount of machine learning so the after
an initial round of annotations we can
start to have the machine record and
tabulate these behaviors automatically
so here we have an example where we have
a mutant indicates with this with other
animals the mutant is in blue and the
other animals are the control animals
and you see that during the light phase
the mutant itself is not actually it
wouldn't actually be discernibly
drinking a whole lot more from the water
spout than the other animals but you can
see that in the dark phase it is
drinking considerably more and more
frequently than the other animals in the
cage and then it was in the late phase
so being able to look at those
statistics and be able to look at it in
comparison with the other animals at the
cage and be able to look at those
statistics and those animals within the
dark and in the late days longer to
Tinley is actually very very important
and it gives us a different insight so
in this case this was a particular
metabolic mutant it was confirming
according to phenotype but our ability
to see that and our ability to quantify
that with something that was a challenge
before but now we can actually quantify
the amount of time is actually spent I'm
actually drinking
again we would have had a video here but
you can see the behavioral overlays so
each animal is identified independently
or identified individually we can see
the interactions between those animals
when we do the analysis then it will
show us what each individual animal is
doing you see here so that we can
actually start to look at no specific
events to occur and say the cage and
specific behaviors from each animal
so again homepage social setting things
are much much different when you look at
animals this way than previously either
looking at them in isolation or just
sort of doing the cage side check or
looking at them and specific functional
assays so in summary the crackit
challenge met by Axel analytics the MRC
and the sponsored by the NC three hours
at the time you know it brought the
analysis into the cage itself and it
allowed us to score a range of behavior
behaviors automatically and now we
actually see that there are clear
effects of group housing versus isolated
housing and clear affects of handling
and clear effects of what is actually
happening in the Bavarian and the
environment outside of the cage and
again as I have said it gives us a very
different end state as to how we been
dealing with with animals in the
laboratory setting you know previous to
know
here was a particular example from mr.c
that actually showed neurodegeneration
and you see that the distance traveled
eight weeks fairly similar between the
two animals but then we actually see
that the neurodegenerative animal starts
to was doing a lot of claiming when we
didn't actually expect it so during the
day time we didn't actually see that
claiming but after we had the ability to
look at it when there was no one I Ryan
we actually saw that that claiming
behavior was actually increased in the
in the nhd animal and then sort of
started to normalize over to overtime
but it was quite surprising to see it
that in the dark phase that this animal
was actually claiming when we didn't
expect it to
and you can actually start to identify
individual outliers so you see our white
or royal pet control cohort is the thick
blue line and then the red and the green
are actually individual animals and we
can see how close those individual
animals are
acting towards those individual animals
are acting towards the well type
controls so the red animal itself is
actually fairly in terms of its pattern
is acting much differently than we
control animals and also the animal in
green so these individual animals are
somewhat conforming to phenotype during
the day but in the evenings the red
animal in particular is an outlier it
was actually very very sick it wouldn't
have been noticed or it would have been
hard to notice it during the daytime but
in the nighttime when we cannot analyze
the data we can see that it's not
confirming to see no type at all and
it's not even close to what the wild
type controls are so that actually gives
us an indication of the welfare of the
animal it was an outlier and we'd have
it had we examined that much closer
would have been close to the ethical
endpoint
and then looking at the current system
we have with the live telemetry and
analysis looking back at the previous
slide this animal in red are ethical
endpoints we're essentially set you can
see that in the graph one on the right
I'm in McDonough Morehead the ethical
endpoint and I'm carried on beyond it so
we identified that outlier with the
system but not through observation and
we more than likely would have been able
to identify it significantly earlier had
we been looking at the other system data
it was only later on afterwards when we
actually started to compare the two the
the observational data from the kids
Capeside check and the data that was
being generated by the system that we
saw that this was indeed an outlier had
that animal gone on or even both of
those animals going on to two subsequent
behavioral cognitive or functional
assays then we might have had a problem
that would have been a possibility that
the results may have been skewed one way
or the other
and then when we look at this continuing
to look at this noodle neurodegenerative
stenotype as an example the ethogram
that shows the locomotor activity in the
claiming activity over a two hour period
either side of light so i'm sure from 6
a.m. to 2 a.m. you see the locomotion
and claiming and both the well type I'm
the NIH the animal were actually very
very high when the lights were off a
little bit more as you would expect in
the well types during the detain but in
the evening the the locomotor activity
for the Nerds generates of animal tht
animal I was actually considerably high
and that's not witnessed at all during
the daytime so almost no climbing at all
during when the lights are on but when
the lights are off quite a lot of
climbing and also the amount of movement
during the daytime would have been about
what we expected but in the evening I
the lights are off you actually are
almost entering a hyperactive disease
so looking at interaction of animals is
obviously very important something that
we can do so here's individual animals
that that we were looking at and we look
at the range of behaviors and those
animals during the light on the dark
phase you can start to spot the outliers
you can start to spot those animals that
were lesion you can see that the TBI
animal is in the and the the light phase
is in red and the in the dark phase it's
in brown or dark red or crimson at the
top so you can see how the animals
reacting in different phases at
different times and you can overlay
those that data on top of each other so
that you'd be able to start to look at
the actual behaviors of these animals
over a long eternal period so this was
over 12 weeks in 3 marbles of trauma and
the amount of social interaction of
those animals are actually doing during
the day during the dark and the light
phase is significantly different
depending on what model that you
actually had
so in light of the fact I didn't have
the videos to show I think that does
actually give a good overview of the
system and I'm hoping that if there are
any questions that I can answer
I'll take them from you but I really
appreciate your time and I think I'll
end it there thanks very much and also
thank you to our collaborators with you
know obviously actual analytics and at
Nissan science also the MRC had headed
up by Sarah Wells our initial partners
AstraZeneca would help us develop the
system and the University of Edinburgh
Queen Mary and the University of
Strathclyde all right thank you very
much thank you dr. Sweeney for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May 14 2019
as a final reminder our speaker will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we will see
you next time goodbye